party oh am i early oh yeah i'm early
hey we're back baby
oh yeah we're back in studio we got so
many drinks
these drinks
they they're really spoiling us here uh
welcome to fandom studios where you can
choose from lemonade soda uh weird
off-brand waters um and uh that's a
green tea i know all of these because i
i'm i love bubbly and green tea
this is a premium small craft kombucha
citrus sunrise flavor that would make me
[ __ ] my pants but uh we're here we're
back in studio uh we the first time
we've seen each other in a couple years
uh in person yeah
looking
i'm gonna say only slightly worse for
wear
not better
to consider better been really hard but
we get more sleep so it balances out
yeah yeah yeah i'm very well rested um
so we're here if this is your first time
watching uh hello welcome to uh the cool
version of like a windows xp desktop
we're back uh here we're talking about
uh the honest trailer for the batman um
which you hopefully have watched before
this as well as the batman honest theme
song that we dropped to the uh yesterday
as a little treat uh we're gonna talk
about our thoughts and feelings about
the movie um deleted scenes that's a
thing we do yeah and uh questions and
comments from viewers like yourselves
they'll be going into the chat and i
will be
sort of checking it out of the corner of
my eyes
so write them in all caps uh we're it's
dif it's different to run the show in
you know reality we're so used to
everything being on like
on my screen and i'm just looking over
there over there but now we're like in
3d meat space it's weird to do this when
i'm not playing elden ring at the same
time this is actually very different you
gotta focus this is wow uh so i guess we
should talk about the batman um
megan v batman
um
it was a good movie and i really liked
it and i think that uh people who say
otherwise are liars and in their heart
of hearts i know that this was actually
the best batman strong since dark knight
or
yeah yeah and i would say up there with
the dark knight as the best modern
modern meaning like post 2000s version
of batman where do you rank this among
your batman well y'all know i don't rank
i have a whole like not ranking system i
don't like to be ranked
but
um
what i will say coming in at number one
hey party people uh welcome back to vh1
i love the batman um but no like it's um
honestly of the post nolan batman's of
which i loved too
uh and the camp batman's this is like a
very i like when they go into a
different direction i like when we see
something new and they did like new
things i really enjoyed this i watched
it
gosh a grip at times yeah i saw it in
theaters which is like i don't see
things in theaters
and this is like a change of face yeah
and this that's a big commitment
watching this movie multiple times
because that's uh that's that's half a
day of your life um
three hours long well also some of it is
because it's our job oh right we have to
true yeah yeah therefore um but i would
i would watch this movie regardless
rank this batman i love this one i think
it's weird because i personally really
like this i i
maybe i think like this and batman
returns are like my two favorite batman
movies yeah and i've just kind of gotta
go like i gotta see this one more and
it's gotta settle in more for me to
decide which is like the one true batman
movie yeah but uh but yeah i it's right
up there having said that i like
weirdly recognize that a lot of the
knocks people have on it are kind of
true like it is incredibly long and
probably enough story for like a limited
series of batman like you could do a six
episode batman show with like this slot
if you just cut half of the slow walking
shots
right under two and a half hours and
like you know i like there's a lot of
knocks on it i feel like that are kind
of legit that that sort of makes sense
we'll talk about this more during the
trailer but like but none of that
bothers me like i was so excited to see
the movie have this consistent tone and
it looks great and it's it's shot in
such a cool way and it really creates
this kind of whole gotham that feels you
know really removed like not not that
it's unrealistic or cartoony or campy
but it doesn't have that nolan like it's
trying to be in our world it's creating
this whole original weird version of the
the dc universe of its own and i i
really dug that yeah it had personality
it felt like matt reeves personal take
on the character and not like it was
just table setting for more batman
movies until the very end um until the
very end you have to by contract by law
you have to have a sprinkle of joker
stuff in there um it's fine um but yeah
no i very much i agree like i liked the
dark and moody but i like that it wasn't
it wasn't like the grim dark that i
think a lot of people now associate with
batman which wasn't always a batman
thing where it's like
everything is sad and life is terrible
and there's a lot of that but there is
like that idea of like batman isn't yes
he's sad yes it sucks yes pearls
everywhere pearls pearls pearls pearls
pearls
pearls pearls pearls i get it but also
there's this feeling that it's like
batman
is doing this
because he's trying to have hope right
and i feel like that's a thing that
doesn't get ex like examined and
explored a lot in a lot of batman movies
i would say it was grim dark and sad for
sure um but i would what i think they
nailed is not since keaton um have they
nailed uh batman and bruce wayne as like
a weird little freak like they explained
like oh he's kind of of course he's
gonna be like a little fidgety strange
like uh insomniac night owl character
yeah and that's not what christian bale
or clooney or kilmer ever felt like we
always want to jump and i get why
filmmakers want to do this when you
think batman when you're like i'm gonna
make a batman movie there's an image we
all have and it's like rain and he's on
the rooftop then he's glowing down at us
and it's this imposing thing and he's
you know he's like the dark knight he's
you know like and and
they they feel like in some way like you
gotta get there you gotta get that
moment in your batman movie or it's not
a batman movie and it's so cool that
this one is like he's just kind of
starting out he's figuring out what it
means to be batman he doesn't he's not
that guy yet he's like kind of this yutz
you know like he's kind of pulling it
together and figuring it out and there
are some scenes where they do just
exactly like you said like like he's
just hiding across the way from catwoman
snooping on her with his banoch yeah and
he's just a weird little creature just
threw a threw a weird dirty hoodie on
over the costume and it and like they
let him be that because it's only year
two or whatever and he's till he's still
got his bat training wheels on and it's
so nice to see it's so refreshing
because we always are jumping right to
frank miller fully formed like tormented
dark knight you know and uh i i i more
all that stuff and it's like yes i like
that we get to i agree we get to see
we've gotten to see batman year one
where it's like oh well here's where he
like goes and fights all these ninjas
and learns how to ninja it up uh and be
the best ninja because that's what we do
with white dudes
they have to become the last samurai
but this one is very much like okay well
i went ninja and then i had like a year
well no i guess i like slip and fall on
stuff i have questions about his ninja
ing but let's let's go into that uh as
we watch the trailer together live in
person for with you too come into the
studio uh wilshire no don't come here do
not come here
don't talk we've had problems in the
past do not come here there's a lot of
security
all right um roll it let's let's watch
this all together
in a world of corruption and chaos the
people cry out for a hero who can join
them in the darkness
darker than that
even darker
darker
that's just a black screen
there we go nice
the batman
uh plus so do you think
we will get slash do we deserve
is there a darker take on batman just
theoretically that one could put on
screen in a major motion picture i i i
mean i guess we could do a radio play
could you already
oh you mean like literally like on the
screen like you can't see anything you
can't see the only thing i can think of
is to do like a like an injustice story
or there's this thing going on of like
um in like the dc multiverse of like the
joker there's like a batman joker hybrid
called like the the batman who laughs i
mean who laughs yeah you're thinking of
the batman who laughs and there and he
like collects uh all these dark universe
variants of batman and one of them is
a sentient version of gotham city um
he's become he's become gotham uh
so i would like it to get that it's like
warhammer 40k with batman but i don't i
think this is probably the theoretical
darkness limit of that because this is
it's a commentary on it it's like the
the journey of bruce wayne slash batman
i guess in this movie is realizing like
oh i have to pull it back this is not
who i'm meant to be like being this you
know like ultimate grim dark i am
vengeance i'm the personification of
fear yes is like not what gotham city
actually needs me to be it needs me to
be this kind of like protector who's in
touch with his humanity so i feel like
now it wouldn't make sense for us to go
even darker we got to kind of pull back
from that a little bit but
it would be hard to top it because you'd
like because it's it's about that in
some ways you'd have to you'd have to go
like almost the parody version to get
beyond yeah but you could i mean i feel
like
it almost is like where zack snyder was
leading his series like the last movie
in that series where it's truly posted
in the apocalypse like that might have
been the most grim darkest like he's
like in a trench coat
punching through people well and i just
um i look i love so many different
versions of batman the campy one
um the uh romantic one uh batman year
one batman year two uh drenched in rain
um wants to make out with someone named
a catwoman um
i love all of these versions of batman
but one that we rarely get to see
that i don't think that anyone will let
us see or it's gotta be a build and
whatever
there is a version of batman that's not
campy not wacky is batman
let me get on my bat soap box for a
minute in the comic books
get on there
um
there are a couple of versions of batman
there is batman having adventures in
gotham there is batman the detective
which is what we get here and we haven't
really seen a lot of before and then
there is batman with the justice league
where it's like dude i guess i'm like
punching an alien in the face i don't
know man i bet you're wondering how i
got here
he is yeah i mean a lot of the justice
league team-up stuff he is like he's the
straight man the money guy he's like the
the so that happened guy where he's just
like i'm just a rich dude bro you know i
just like
throw this uh thing at him yeah you
better get in there green lantern he's
mostly like he winds up being the
planner where it's like he's the dude in
the chair right except he's like in the
field but that winds up being a lot of
like i can't imagine this version of him
ever getting there but we'll see well i
mean that's that's like the one thing
that yeah like this version of batman
has not developed yet is the like
yeah like you know they say like batman
if he's got time to plan he can beat
anybody you know like like batman with
like myself
yeah with leg work
i think that's real coffee you're
drinking
uh and i i think like we don't really
there's not he's not very good at
planning yet in this right like he kind
of gets foiled by the people who are
good at planning because they outsmart
him and they have plans that he gets
caught up in uh so i feel like maybe
that's where the future sequels go is
like him big getting higher level in
figuring out how to like take the bird's
eye view of the situation and make a
plan get more detective yeah
all right let's keep watching
watch robert pattinson put the final
stake in his twilight sparkle and give
us the first truly gen z version of
batman his villains are influencers hey
guys
thanks for all the comments he's worse
off than his parents if this continues
it won't be long before you've nothing i
don't care about that and his hometown
will very soon be underwater
i have nothing to
add i had i had like eight more
how batman is gen z jokes we cut it down
to the best one i'm trying to think of
what some of the others are his
girlfriend is bi was definitely trouble
with trouble with face-to-face
interaction yeah right he's not good
yeah uh i'm trying to try to think it
was at least at least seven right i can
look him up keep playing the trailer
first first gen z batman uh back in
gotham a city that's one part new york
and now eight part seattle
in this puddle of sin hunts the riddler
a guy who talks a big game about
cleaning up the city for someone dressed
like a garbage bag he'll do more to stop
corruption than batman ever has with
nothing but a roll of duct tape
a barista's sense of flare and the most
hardcore followers ever he's been posted
online it's got like 500 followers
french types how is it that
two things there one i was really
obsessed with the milk foaming thing
like
are we are we imagining this seedy
24-hour gotham diner is making him a
cappuccino no he's do it you can kind of
see him i think he has like a swizzle
stick or something now you can see him
like popping right back people pointed
that out to me that he's making
they didn't design the question mark
fomart for him he's doing that himself
but when was the last time you had a
cappuccino served to you and what where
are they getting foamed milk to begin
with i mean that's well
that's a cappuccino it's a in that diner
you think that diner has a cappuccino
machine again you have never been to
seattle
all right this is that's sucks right
that diner has a cappuccino i feel like
that diner is you you got the two you
got the two coffee bun pots
there's the black one and then the
oranges in the gentrifying part of
gotham and the orange one has regular
coffee in it at least halfway okay but
you've been to swingers like you know
you could get there's that's not a cafe
one-on-one
did swingers make it through the picture
no swingers is swingers cafe 101 has
been reopened but it's like new
management though
yeah that's a shame welcome back to
diner talking yeah you guys can talk
about that
i don't know i had another thing there
too with the 500 the 500 followers where
it's like
a lot of people are making fun of you
know riddler only having 500 followers
well when they're when they're that
engaged i think that was what i was
going to say is like we you we have a
lot more followers but we don't have
that kind of engagement we could be like
hey leave us a comment in like four
people
yeah these guys are like buying matching
outfits
they're getting guns they're they're
organized that's an incredible level of
the game we need a mic for ryan he would
be way more
way more posters uh or followers if like
he's on the news like he would
definitely have more than oh
why can't i think of a more modern
reference than tila tequila
wow
20 year old viral star dealer
who's a viral star you guys know that
star wars kid it's like the ikea monkey
i always say
[Laughter]
get 500 dudes to do terror stuff but
might get barely 10 percent of you to
like and subscribe yeah what do you want
from me riddles murders movie fights
so pause
um first of all i wonder if uh putting
up that graphic will actually help
people like unsubscribe because like
every other channel does that it's sure
is that annoying do you think that's
annoying uh if not
we'll keep doing it let us know i mean
let us know in the comments like
subscribe if you think it's annoying
smash that like button that's the
annoying thing about about youtube is
like
as of now there's so many things that
are obnoxious but everyone does them
because they work of like think people
like with their face in the thumbnail
making the like
and it's like batman dead
text that has nothing to do with the
rest of the video
every honest trailer commentaries for
the next like month i think should be
one of us going
and then batman death
just see how that clicks ryan let's
let's get on that we'll see how that
clicks yeah yeah uh but we did make that
uh we did tease that uh movie fights
thing and i thought look we're back in
studio there's three of us we're not at
a podium
um should we do a movie fight i guess we
gotta sure let's do a movie fight i
think we've been actually gathering some
some questions here and i guess we can
choose them we've done obviously no prep
for really anything
oh yeah yeah roll that [ __ ] it's time
for screen junkies
yeah
hell yeah
so that that takes me back um but we've
got some movie fights here um dan's
brain is tingling right now dan like dan
just like stood straight up on a couch
in
little rock arkansas it's that literal
picture of like during uh bruce wayne
and batman returns where he like stands
up and looks over in the stick yeah this
is like throwing up the dancing i feel
like dan has now become the monster from
it follows and it's just walking in a
direct line to the studio no matter what
gets in front of him he's going to be
chasing
until one of us has sex which i think is
what that movie was about
all right so uh from so we can go uh
from adam asa nolan or reeves uh we can
fight well there's three of us let's do
let's do more um
from john who should the villains for
the sequel be
uh or
okay i like this one from pat now that
pattinson is batman and kristen stewart
is lady die what role should taylor
lautner play to make a come back to pop
culture
wow great question
yeah i think let's uh let's marinate on
that for a second
um
i'm going to say uh powdered toastman in
a live action ren and stimpy movie hmm
oh okay so it's not batman
exclusive no anything no you're just
casting taylor a lot nervous i'm gonna
be assisting pop culture i'm gonna say i
think we bring back uh shark boy but
it's grim dark adult gritty shark
yeah
his his own role he was he was oh is he
lava in shark boy level he was shark boy
and shark boy and lava girl and i'm
saying he reprising his own greatest
role okay so he's back
3d not like not things constantly coming
out at you just like you're in the room
with him while he's being emo i think
that
nope i i started saying it oh you gotta
finish your sentence that's fine i think
that he should do the lead character in
a remake of the 80s movie soul man
wow
god
okay all right i'll let danielle start
oh god okay um
yeah
i did this to me
ding ding ding okay take a large sip of
a drink
so in the 80s
we were taking
big old swings and one of those swings
was the idea that um
uh uh
affirmative action was so horrible that
if you were a white kid or uh just a kid
that was not black um you needed
to you were locked out of the system you
were locked out of the system and so in
the movie soul man a a a a child figures
out who lost his entire career after
that because you made that movie um
figures out a way through experimental
pills that another smart friend of his
had to increase his melanin production
it was a pills thing yeah
it's not never
oh it is it is black there was a black
thing in making the movie but in the
reality of the film
he's he's taking melanin pills yeah yes
and so he becomes he he gets to college
uh now tell me why taylor lautner is the
right choice for this
uh because like that person who played
him in the movie they both have
exceedingly white teeth
wow i mean airtight case okay thank you
now i i said powdered toastman from red
and stimpy because i feel like he needs
to get into like the superhero genre you
know play something more heroic like a
really physical role and um
i feel like he's probably got a nice
butt so he could fly backwards and
really shake that moneymaker yeah and um
it seems like
he has the range and the vocal presence
to maybe play a large piece of toast and
to say things like powdered toast man
what's great is those are like two lines
that he has so
i think he says that in really a modern
day gary owens taylor
all right what's your taylor water pitch
oh uh well i mean he listen he already
knows the ins and outs of the sharkboy
and lava girl universe and i think that
any attempt to revisit the sharkboy lava
girl verse which i think is also the spy
kids verse am i crazy about that i
assume so i think this is all robert
rodriguez because they all because they
just did that netflix one we are heroes
which i think is also said in the same
verse so if you're gonna bring back the
spy kids verse you got to know all the
details the fans are going to demand
that level of specificity so it makes
sense for taylor lautner to return there
because he knows that world so well but
i think that we could all real i mean
generationally
kids the kids of that era are crying out
to go back and revisit that world but in
a more serious and mature way that lines
up with who they are now how they've
grown since their experiences with the
first shark boy in lava it's such a safe
pick lon at least danielle's willing to
go out on the edge and get all of us
reverse canceled i mean
i i'm trying not to say everything i
would like to say welcome to movies yeah
i respect it i respect the effort and i
think that um i want taylor lautner to
branch out into something new and have
like a self-aware sense of humor about
himself to be like you know what people
think of me as this kind of lumpin
oafish
that's me who can't
like uh like like lumpy muscles he's
like very like bulbous yes he's got a
bulbous body yeah and i think that
that's um
and again he can appeal to an older
generation so people that didn't grow up
with twilight um
90s kids if you will and i think that
this is like a this is sort of branching
out but still well within his wheelhouse
so i'm i'm going to powdered toast man
and uh final closing statements and then
you you the voter can uh can write in
the comments below who you think won was
it or should we
go ahead close it out yeah close out uh
listen
sharkboy and lava girl but but dark and
gritty this time it's a take we've never
seen that that world is so colorful that
world is so bright what would it look
like if that was a ruined dystopic world
i think we all would like to know i
think we're all curious to see okay
great soul man is also dark
that's very dystopian soul man is very
dystopian if you can name the actor
who played the soul man i think you win
yeah
oh off the top of my head yeah i can't i
can only remember because i i maybe i
blocked it i can only remember that his
love interest was rae don chong yes um
there you go i'm giving it that thing
and james earl jones was also aided as
his advice
we could do a whole uh verse of um
cancelable comedy reboots we do that we
do ladybugs we do joanna man we throw
them i guess silver streak silver streak
everybody pretending to be
does some like it hot count i don't know
ah i feel like you could probably get
away with something like it hot yeah i
think it goes through the portal or like
the bird cage yeah you know we're
bringing it all back um so there you go
uh what were we talking about again the
batman batman yeah comment below if you
think we won or we should never do these
again
yeah the last four let's keep watching
the truth yeah you demanded it the first
batman who's both psychologically
vulnerable and physically invincible
but what this batman really wants to do
is detect watch the world's not quite
greatest detective decode ciphers thanks
to his butler i've taken the liberty of
doing a little work on this latest
cipher solve riddles thanks to gotham's
finest convention with a freaking carpet
tool it's a
a tanker and kills however many truck
drivers it takes to answer the mystery
who is elrod
i know batman kills in every film
it's not a huge hang up for me like it
is for somebody it's just funny that
this one he's killing innocent people a
lot of innocent people on the road
granted he's chasing the penguin so he's
but the fact that is he's chasing the
penguin
a man who's very visible and easy to
find at any moment and he's doing it to
have a conversation with him that
really he could have sent gordon to just
like check he has he has no he has no
proof that that's the the culprit he's
it's a hunch he's he's chasing him on
just like the chance that this is the
guy he's looking for well maybe if he
was shouting out the window check your
texts like it would be better how how's
your spanish
pretty good
kind of struggling with this one
translation i'm not mad at because i
think this was i mean this was there
aren't many action sequences in the
movie but i think this one was like a
show stopper for me
it's hard to do something that i know
wasn't new but it felt new and fresh and
like a batmobile scene but man yeah
the
yeah reeves stylistically and and in
terms of the the way that the movie is
sort of shot and put together he like he
like gets that that build up you know
like that that the patience of letting
it like when he's revving the batmobile
and the penguin is looking at it and
you're you're building that moment he
just like lets it kind of sit and and
that that works uh that works so well
but yeah uh
just uh he kills a lot of people to get
very little very little information
a rudimentary basically just a
translation of
all he gets out of it he also asks uh
why did they call that man the penguin
well they don't yet do they yeah though
he's referred to is it just that he owns
that place that's called the iceberg
lounge i guess that's what we're meant
to take i mean they did like a nod
because like when he has his hands and
feet tied together he like kind of want
to put that and i feel like just for us
in my head and somebody saw him like
nelson was like
you're the penguin now they're already
calling him penguin
and uh you know normally you would think
of like well he's a little wobbly guy or
he made like burgess meredith he does
the little bird sounds or he's always in
a tuxedo or but none of those things
seem to apply to this man he it feels
like his name would be like jimmy the
nose or something
yeah um prune face yeah i was like joey
bag of donuts is that guy not the
penguin
also it does seem like it's one of those
names where it's like well if you're not
doing anything outwardly penguin-like
that's just rule you'd be right yeah you
wouldn't you wouldn't maybe because he
rolls with falcone like everybody needs
a bird nickname it's like they're the
original bird game it's birds they're
the bird gang that's the bird gang yeah
bird gang burger oh wow
[Laughter]
the rat with wings hmm let me think here
a rat with wings that could be anyone
that penguin
oh no where's robin
join batman in the second year in the
job so it's not just a face okay dad oh
you're not my father but before he had
the justice league bruce was stuck
working with the gotham police mustache
division featuring james gordon a man
doing his best to get fired by bringing
a weird fetish goth to every crime scene
whoa whoa
are you kidding me sir you gonna let him
in here i got the price downstairs he's
a goddamn vigilante he could be a
suspect you're really okay with this
what about chain of evidence
plus an assist from alfred who gave
director matt reeves his greatest
performance ever and was rewarded with
the role of guy caught in the blast
radius
alfred didn't get much
in this version i liked andy circus in
it but yeah yeah i thought it's not his
fault
is he even a butler i don't even know if
we get confirmation that he's doing any
buddling he has a maid so he's not doing
a tunnel there's one scene where uh
pattinson enters the room and he goes oh
there's some berries over there if you
want that's the only butlering that's
done the entire movie i've been
rewatching
the butler of a house is actually more
of like the manager yeah right he's like
the office manager yeah yeah well like
mr bates on downton abbey he's not the
best he's not missed about jordan is the
bird you're right you're right mr carson
mr bats mr bates is
uh but yeah he's not like feather
dustering he's like running all the
other servants but there's only one
other servant in in wayne
i think he's fired them all at this
point it's like he's just wearing he's
wearing the same shirt again guys he
just seems like other guy who lives in
bruce wayne's house for the most part
good at puzzles so they
so they hint to the idea that he uh
talks a little bit about like his
training when he was in like the
military or whatever yeah he mentioned
he thought bruce judo or whatever right
which is like part of that is a huge
alfred trope is that like he so like
he'd which is why and i don't know if
they full out explain it in this um this
is why he's able to uh know how to
decipher uh cryptic texts that's what
they teach you in the army right
i think he's like
yeah he was like special air service or
british intelligence like there's a lot
of major there's a lot of alfred
backstory where he was like working and
he was like a government spy before he
and and then penny worked that epic show
right now
but it's about that it's like that's the
premise is that he was doing covert spy
stuff before he worked make sure and go
back and watch our interview with the
cast of pennywork you don't have to find
you don't have to probably do this
but also yeah so that was my most takes
are very much like i'm alfred i'm the
butler and they don't they kind of
hinted that stuff so this was the first
one where i was like oh well he was left
in charge because like they don't want
to have bruce be a lindbergh baby you
know
yeah and i also do think that they they
i don't think that this batman uh
got ninja you know i think he
i think this version the way he fights
the way he moves he's not stealthy in
any way shape or form he just kind of
clumps in and and beats ass so i think i
think alfred just taught him some some
krav maga i feel like alfred taught him
some stuff and he took like you know
like some taekwondo lessons in gotham
somewhere you know like
like a foot fist way type scenario you
know like yeah i don't i don't think
this is this is not a like he moved to
nepal i don't think we've gotten here
picked a
blue flower that only grows on that one
slope yeah yeah well save roswell goal
for the the batman too too fast and
furious that's when he bangs that's
where he bangs
keep playing
woman a bi motorcycle burglar with lots
of cats and daddy issues mwah perfection
i mean i have no notes together they'll
take on cd underworld types like balcony
do you have notes i did such a great job
not getting into the wigs i felt very
proud oh yeah yes i actually made a note
i made a note in my notes that said like
i am holding myself back
and all of you should be grateful for it
finally got around to teaching people
how to pronounce his name falcone paid
him off she just stood up to falcone
head of the falcone crime family how
cool is the red a version of colin
farrell so gross it almost ruins his sex
tape and a city-wide conspiracy
bruce could have stopped by showing up
to his day job like once our accounting
friends at wayne enterprises are coming
for breakfast i haven't got time for
this there's no time alfred some brown
teenagers are playing the knockout game
i mean i know that he's starting out and
uh you know he's getting his uh his
detective legs under him but
it takes a certain level of oblivious to
not even
have an inkling that your family
foundation is the honey pot for every
single crime and corrupt
organization in the entire city and
you're like where's all this crime
coming from
it's like everybody is just hand over
fist looting the wayne the wayne
foundation well no it's not it's it's
the gotham
fund which is what thomas wayne created
right with his own money yeah outside of
politics but it's not it like i i think
the
i'm being you know but like i think
they're two separate accounts there's
the the wayne foundation is not the same
account as the slush fund he just also
has control over the sludge fund and has
been ignoring it
so he's so he's totally up
now i'm just saying there's two counts
one is the slush fund one is just wayne
enterprises and that's the one that
alfred's looking at like you're gonna be
broke if you don't do a better job sir
right it's a good oak groudon it's like
okay well then where do you get a cave
yeah where are you gonna get a cave wait
i was
the location like is is he in the bat
cave or is he underneath like an unused
i think in some way it looks like he's
under he's under like downtown yeah yeah
like because they they show that it's
it's under the tower right right yeah so
it's not usually we do like wayne manor
and then the backyard is underneath and
it's on like the outskirts but there
have been some what's like underweighing
towers right but like i'd love to see
that was like the nolan ones where it
was like well actually uh we're still in
the city i want to see this version of
pattinson really grimly
in his like hoodie and jeans get on a
fireball and slide down and when he
lands he's in the bed like a bust of
shakespeare and he's got a little knob
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
good morning
[Laughter]
so enjoy a really really really
ridiculously good looking batman movie
which was necessary since it's also a
really really really ridiculously long
batman movie
where they just let good filmmakers
stick a duh in front of the name and
have their way with it until warner
brothers does their usual executive
shuffle thing and i don't know crams a
joker into everything again
oh come on
all right story um
i mean look
in a world where everything becomes
jokerfied eventually in a world where
everything becomes joker yeah
listen we live in a society so as long
as we continue to live in a society
we'll continue to do joker stuff yeah um
do you
a hope that the the batman 2 is
jokerfied and b
are you cool with the choice of uh barry
kyogen kogan keegan keegan uh third
time's the charm yeah i drewy we call
him jerusalem
um
not the actor but sucks yeah i you know
i would rather them not go back to the
joker well right now i was really
interested in a new take on the riddler
um if they do it i'll watch it i will
give benefit the doubt because i really
like this and i will give benefit of the
doubt my gum is literally falling out of
my mouth i am a disgusting human i
apologize um yeah i'll give benefit of
the doubt um that it'll be good and that
uh they've casted it correctly because i
think that they did a great job with
casting on this but
it's not
i'm not the most psyched for that yeah
i did not really love the deleted i
think they were smart to remove the
deleted scene that we saw later i think
it was too long it wouldn't have fit you
don't need joker there he didn't really
add much but i really like the scene
that's in this movie at the end where
joker and riddler are in arkham that
feels very like ongoing batman
continuity to me and that's what i like
so much about this whole version of it
is that it doesn't feel like well in the
first movie we're doing this i mean
obviously it's a riddler is the main
villain but you get penguin you get
catwoman you get falcone you get you get
like
it's a whole bunch of interconnected
gotham stories are all happening and my
hope is that they would keep doing that
and i like joker being in the mix i
think barry king is a good good casting
choice and i like joker being he's there
he's present we don't have to do the guy
falling into the vat of acid birth he's
just active and a presence in this
gotham but i don't i don't know if i
would say he needs to be like the main
villain like i like him being there i
don't think they can resist though
it's gonna be hard for them to resist
but i in the same way that scarecrow was
always in the nolan films right but it
was never like this is the scarecrow
film i feel like it seems like half and
half scarecrow yeah but i mean i feel
like that's what joker could be like
joker got out of arkham during this
story and he's got a scheme going but
it's maybe not the only villain
storyline maybe it's like two faces also
in that one right and they're teasing
him with like
obviously like the gang of clowns and
you can tell that the black clown is the
good clown because only half of his face
is clown yeah the other one is black
it's not you know symbolism or something
he's only half clown
but half you know man the other ones
there could be none more clown
before nigel toughnells i do love uh
barry keegan so i i i'd be interested to
see and he is a all-time little creep in
uh killing a mistake yeah well i mean
putting the the power of putting keegan
and paul dano in the same movie like the
weird little creep factor off the chair
off the charts yeah uh and patented in
this one so yeah i love the weird little
creep version yeah none more creep all
right let's wrap this up we'll get to
your questions
gerard wayne undercuts oh
the right man for the job
crime ally
incelsior
the big lebowski
the tumbler
colin farrow watching the old daredevil
movies
hey come on capes together strong
martinez that guy's the homie and druix
sucks
the twinite saga
there you go um
awesome well okay so keep your uh keep
your questions and comments coming in
fast and furious um or even about fast
and furious
too uh and in the meantime do we have
any deleted scenes any cut jokes let's
roll
edward sullivan
claw enforcement leather goal
let her go
by curious
the right to remain silent gore to death
the hippocratic oaf twitch army man
there will be flood riddle miss sunshine
lonely fans they're all paul daniels
with the jesus
falcon punch
why it's
gotham's next top waddle
monty python's dying circus
and the killing of a sacred joke
wordle
not even ones
a bat a cat an adhesive face
riddles and bits
this is definitely bruce wayne's first
kiss ever right yeah for sure yeah
yeah that was very um
michael jackson and uh imani i remember
the time yeah
yeah yeah it's a little
it's a little weird
i just i like michael jackson kissing
it's just it's impossible to imagine
this version of bruce wayne kissing a
girl like i tried yeah well i was
watching this scene the very first time
i was like that's definitely his first
kiss and then i thought about that
version of bruce wayne kissing another
girl and i was like yeah no way it was
definitely this um but i want to see the
training montage where
this bruce wayne has to learn to become
a playboy and it's like you just like do
hitch
it's just
that should be the second film it's just
him learning how to be that's what
lucious job is oh my gosh this job is
just coming in hitch oh my god
done and he's played by queen latifah
you're you're selling me on this pretty
hard like i'm picking up and i'm pretty
much ready to go uh all right so let's
let's go to some questions great
opportunity to introduce vicki vale
you've already got selena kyle you bring
in vicki vale you do pamela eisley
you're all you're all set now or you can
bring in keaton because he's just
showing up in everything now and it's
like
you want to get nuts you want to get
nuts no no it's you want to get nuts yes
you want to get these okay
oh
[Music]
wow yeah oh still got it i'm i'm so glad
we didn't delete any of the uh
make more of those um i need a graphic
for when i start to say something that i
know i shouldn't finish
and we just have a siren
we also need a we need a wig
and a wig talk we need a wig talk right
now
wait just go through them all i want to
know what we still have
breaking news
yeah yeah sure
wow
i feel like
jte never triggered any of these no
never
there are honestly a few of these i've
never seen
yeah okay
listen there was a lot of important
stuff happening in that booth okay i
think we need to get yeah there was a
lot of a lot of movie things were going
on there was a lot of movie thinking we
need to get our graphics folks to drop
everything they're doing right now and
make a new round of random segway
graphics i want this to look like a 1989
drive time uh
the ones where
think the three i can think of
immediately two for danielle one the the
train of thought danielle one the wig
talk one and then is this a red notice i
feel oh yeah
it should just be called red notice red
nose
the red notice alarm and it's like the
rock swinging in ryan reynolds
oh wow oh wow
spoiler alert sure
as useful this is the billy wrap it up
which we will use soon
i can't see from here who's that in the
that's billy as if he's david harper
sure of course
good good to know all right so now uh
after that important stuff i think we
have time for one fan question ah listen
our graphics versus your questions it's
obvious we're coming back in we're we're
jumping back into it it's obvious where
we're gonna go with that
um let's see uh well we can take a few
um
like life questions uh yeah uh langley
amelia is leaving the house for work a
new experience post pandemic not my
favorite no i mean this has been fun
it's been fun to see yeah i do this
actually really
yeah it was actually really nice i
haven't seen either of them in person in
like years it's really nice no honestly
i would say after i've been because i
live alone so you know after two years
every day just working in my apartment
with just me and taco like this has been
it's been really nice and i live with
two other people in very close quarters
so it's been really nice yeah like i've
i've enjoyed getting that like you know
you don't you know this is gonna work as
work and you're like go to back to work
but you don't do it for two years and
part of you is like you know what would
be fun i could use a second location
that would work yeah that's right yeah
like i feel like uh i feel like a home
dude whose name i can't remember but
someone in the comments well in the
hatch and lost where it's like i just
have my routine yeah i'm drinking my
green juice and i'm working out and then
all of a sudden uh looking at it ryan
cameron opened up the cat at the hatch
and was like hey danielle we're going
back to the studio his name is desmond
desmond thank you
not pennies and then another set
question from evan j pretzel what does
the new set smell like nothing yet but
we're working on it oh we're gonna get
our stank all over it yeah
me very soon but nothing yet look we're
going to cover it like cats uh aditya
asks in the batman sequel what tattoo
should they give the joker so we know
he's damaged
um i think it should still be damaged
but like in sanskrit
so it's he's like a little bit more new
age he's got that like weird gross skin
he's got some skin problems yeah i feel
like he's gonna impact tattoo quality
that's for sure that's true that's true
uh so maybe like more of a lower back
yeah i just think he should definitely
get ha ha ha ha ha oh my god tattooed
all over himself so people know like oh
yeah
he finds this funny or [ __ ] stamp which
is just like ha ha ha ha ha just like
afraid at the small of his back yeah
it's gorgeous good um
and i'm not really liking any of your
questions
yeah this can probably work in this
version of batman
i can't see him taking on like a ward at
this point because he'd be like 12. but
i mean that is that's that is
traditionally yeah yeah yeah i just um i
mean
yo i mean he's very withholding but the
idea they were kind of teasing it where
it's like he's following around this
okay there's no version of this that i
say that doesn't sound creepy with this
batman it isn't hard to avoid when
you're talking about robin i feel like
you have to do role reversal where it's
like this batman is kind of an amateur
and a fuck-up and he brings in a robin
who's like immediately way higher level
than him like he brings in like an
ex-military guy who like already has a
lot of good ideas about batman he's like
wait
you bet this has been how you're doing
it because
you're just going to crime scenes with
all the cops there
what are you thinking they're going to
catch you okay yeah yeah there's i'm
sure there's a way to do it but i can't
i can't imagine somebody in bright red
green and yellow in this universe i
don't think that would work at all you'd
have to totally nightwing it up like
from the from the start yeah i don't
feel like he's going to like see the
flying graysons and it all just happens
no no you'd have to come up with some
origin that feels like it fits it's all
bloodhaven it's got to be i visited i
did there was a bloodhaven uh shoutout
there was there was because zoe kravitz
said she's going to go maybe to blood
all right well there you go you guys um
this has been sweet uh let's do it again
uh next week where we come back
um
first of all before we come back to that
there uh eric and uh has kim seen the
movie who else is doing it with eric or
is it just eric for the spoilers yeah
eric
theoretically bailey eric kim and
theoretically bailey
who was the best bailey have all seen
she's definitely seeing the movie so i
feel like she'll be in for that they
they've all seen doctor strange two and
they'll be doing a spoiler chat live
right here on this very desk uh in
monday i gotta put my stink all over it
before they get here yeah they don't get
our musk deep in we'll be at the desk
because kid lives in england but we're
working
here
it's a quick 12-hour jaunt by plane
just get kim i think we should get uh
the d.a and uh tape them up and make
them just hold
one of the microphones what did you
think of doctor strange
uh and other surprise guests uh that
billy is writing in this group aka i'm
booking people
benedict cumberbatch yeah so we're
working we'll have something to do on
monday and then we'll be back on tuesday
for another honest trailer commentary
for
uh a movie
the movie equivalent i'm leaving
[Music]
of drinking
this at room temperature
and then i think it's more like the
equivalent
so many drinks uh yeah it's the movie
equivalent of uh having a sip of tap
water um and then going about your day
it's the movie equivalent of telling
someone hey i'm kind of thirsty can i
get a drink with a little like yes i'll
bring you a drink in a few minutes and
then they never bring you a drink
are you thirsty are you thirsty oh man
i'm looking forward to uh enjoying a
cool sip of water very soon you like
water you like water and then it's never
around you could call it an movie
so that's a clue for next week we'll see
you then right here i guess on another
episode of australia commentaries
bye-bye
[Music]
you